[Music]
i'm jules van binsbergen the nippon life
professor in finance at the wharton
school at the university of pennsylvania
and i'm jonathan burke apg professor of
finance at the graduate school of
business at stanford university and we
hope you'll join us on a journey where
we explore the science and strategy of
better decision making on all else equal
a new podcast from the stanford graduate
school of business and the wharton
school together we have been teaching
and studying business decision making
for over 40 years and in that time we've
learned about the most common mistakes
that people make we've also learned a
thing or two about how to explain those
mistakes to decision makers particularly
after having made them repeatedly
ourselves in this podcast series we look
at the ways people make mistakes and how
we can learn from their mistakes we'll
talk to business leaders about choices
they have had to make and we'll show you
a framework you can use to become a
better decision maker not just on the
job but in your personal life as well
over the years one of the things we have
found is that abstract theoretical
concepts just don't resonate with people
what does resonate are concrete examples
and that insight is the basis of the
case method in business schools by
explaining a general principle in the
context of an interesting example the
ideas become interesting and fun to talk
about it is also how people remember
ideas there's lots of research that
shows that concreteness is key to how
the brain stores ideas in each podcast
we'll discuss specific interesting
examples and we will invite successful
leaders to talk about their personal
experience making the mistake
why it was so costly and how they try to
avoid him in the future and so in our
first few episodes we will explore a
number of business decision-making
situations where ignoring the reaction
of the world around you leads to the
wrong decision this is why we've decided
to call the podcast all else equal when
you make a decision the world around you
reacts it's not just the world is
constantly changing it is the world
changes because of the decisions you
make
this type of all else equal thinking is
the common thread through the podcast
series make sure to catch each episode
by following or subscribing to our show
wherever you listen to your podcasts for
more information and episodes visit all
elseequalpodcast.com
[Music]
you